l'affaiblissement de l'occident au coeur
des discussions de la conférence sur la
sécurité de munich
cette 56e édition s'est clôturée sur la
situation en libye
une situation qui reste profondément
préoccupante avec un processus de paix
en panne
l'onu appelle à plus de négociation y
dresse un constat alarmant face aux
multiples violations de cessez-le-feu
la situation sur le terrain reste très
inquiétante la trêve ne tient qu'à un
fil avec de nombreuses violations plus
de 150 enregistrés et c'est le peuple
libyen qui continue à souffrir le plus
pour le ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian les
partenaires européens doivent participer
davantage au règlement de cette crise
j'ai été très frappée de constater que
sur trois sujets de crise majeure nous
avions parlé ensemble pris des
initiatives ensemble et qu'ils étaient
des initiatives européennes et qui ont
recueilli le consensus l'une le luigi
viens d'en parler concerné la libye aux
initiatives européennes accord européen
la rencontre de berlin initiative
européenne
un scénario à nada qui proposait et
demain des initiatives complémentaires
qui seront prises les européens sont à
la manoeuvre sur une crise de leur
proximité première participation à cet
événement pour emmanuel macron le
président français a rappelé que la
russie était un partenaire à ne pas
négliger mais a taclé moscou sur sa
politique de déstabilisation des
démocraties occidentales en europe
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs dans toutes les démocraties
au monde les mutations du système
médiatico technologiques sont telles que
nous n'avons plus les anticorps pour
protéger la démocratie donc la russie
continuera à être un acteur de ce sujet
et je pense que d'ailleurs dans
l'initiative qu'on doit mener
on doit construire la stratégie de
désescalade mais aussi de transparence
commune qu'on fera sur ces sujets et moi
je pense que dans les prochains mois ce
qu'on doit essayer de faire avec la
russie sur ce point c'est si des acteurs
privés russe ou publiques russes se
mettent dans de telles stratégies dans
toutes nos démocraties ou celle de nos
partenaires
on doit mettre en place une méthodologie
d'action rapide mais peut-être aussi
d'attribution beaucoup plus clair est
beaucoup plus forte et de systèmes de
sanctions
emmanuel macron qui a aussi fait part de
son impatience face à la chancelière
allemande angela merkel sur les réformes
de l'europe
il a invité l'allemagne à s'impliquer
davantage dans les affaires européennes
en matière de défense aux conférences
sous forme de règlements de compte pour
le gouvernement allemand qui peine à
trouver un successeur à la chancelière
plusieurs favoris sont en lice parmi eux
et armin laschet membres de la cedeao le
parti conservateur donc la merkel mais
malgré cette appartenance hier à munich
il n'a pas mâché ses mots envers la
chancelière il a critiqué son manque de
réactivité face aux propositions des
manuels mâcon pour relancer le projet
européen rouler coûte
j'aurai donc tout d'abord souhaité une
réponse plus engagés à macron plus
rapide et aussi l'engagement d'une
discussion il a fait le discours de la
sorbonne avec des propositions
substantielles est importante pour
l'europe
il aura pu s'attendre à une réponse
allemandes engagées à ce sujet d'abord
la crise financière mondiale puis la
crise de la dette européenne
puis la crise migratoire puis le conflit
entre l'ukraine et la russie ou
l'allemagne et la france ont assumé un
rôle majeur de médiation puis le bric
cite également ce n'était peut-être pas
le temps des grandes visions européenne